now to las vegas as miranda lambert gets  excited for her new las vegas  [Music]  want to make residency  something different not only for the  fans but for us as a band too i think it  will keep us on our toes  and miranda is stepping out of her  comfort zone for her performances i want  to have some elements of the show that  i've maybe never done before  whether it's a wardrobe change or like a  couple of acoustic songs by myself  [Music]  vegas should be special you know i think  if people are gonna follow the way to  vegas and come to a show it really needs  to be special the miranda lambert velvet  rodeo residency opens friday september  23rd for a run of 24 shows at zappos  theater the name sets it up right those  two works together really inspired me  creatively for the look of everything if  i was a cowboy  i'm just gonna work my butt off this  year and that feels right you know  [Music]